let me ask the overmantel size question
do you think we'll ever engineer an AGI
system that we humans would be able to
love and that would love us back so have
that level and depth of connection I
love that question and it it it relates
closely to things that I've been
thinking about a lot lately you know in
the context of this human AI research
there there's social psychology research
in particular by Susan Fiske at
Princeton in the department I used to
where I used to work where she she
dissects human attitudes toward other
humans into a sort of two dimensional
you know a two-dimensional
two-dimensional scheme and one dimension
is about ability you know how able how
capable is this this other person and
the but the other dimension is warmth so
you can imagine another person who's
very skilled and capable but it's very
cold right and you wouldn't you wouldn't
really like highly you might have some
reservations about that other person
right but there's also a kind of
reservation that we might have about
another person who who elicits in us or
displays a lot of human warmth but is
you know not good at getting things done
right that that like the greatest esteem
that we we reserved our greatest esteem
really for people who are both highly
capable and also quite warm right that
that's that's like the best of the best
this is I mean I'm just this isn't a
normative statement I'm making this is
just an empirical it's an empirical
statement this is what humans seem this
is these are the two dimensions that
people seem to kind of like along which
people size other people up and an in AI
research we really focus on this
capability thing you're like we want our
agents to be able to do stuff you know
this thing can play go at it superhuman
level that's awesome
and but that's only one dimension what's
the what about the other dimension what
would it mean for
an AI system to be warm and you know I
don't know maybe there are easy
solutions here like we can put them put
a face on rei systems it it's cute it
has big years I mean that's probably
part of it
but I think it also has to do with a
pattern of behavior a pattern of you
know what would it mean for an AI system
to display caring compassionate behavior
in a way that actually made us feel like
it was for real yeah that we didn't feel
like it was simulated we didn't feel
like we were being duped to me that you
know people talk about the Turing test
or some some descendant of it I feel
like that's the ultimate Turing test you
know is there is there an AI system that
can not only convince us that it knows
how to reason and it knows how to
interpret language but that we're
comfortable saying yeah that AI system
is a good guy you know like I'm the
warmth scale yeah whatever warmth is we
kind of intuitively understand it but we
also want to be able to yeah we don't
even understand it explicitly enough yet
to be able to engineer it exactly and
that's and that's an open scientific
question you kind of alluded it several
times in the human AI interaction that's
the question that should be studied and
probably one of the most important
questions and usually and human to AG
humans are so good at it yeah you know
it's not just weird it's not just that
we're born warm you know they're like I
suppose some people are are warmer than
others given you know whatever genes
they managed to inherit but there's also
there's also there are also learned
skills involved right I mean there are
ways of communicating to other people
that you care that they matter to you
that you're enjoying interacting with
them right and we learn these skills
from one another
and it's not out of the question that we
could build engineered systems
I think it's hopeless as you say that we
can somehow hand design these sorts of
these sorts of behaviors but it's not
out of the question that we could build
systems that kind of we we we we in
instill in them something that
sets them out in the right direction so
that they they end up learning what it
is to interact with humans in a way
that's gratifying to humans I mean
honestly if that's not where we're
headed
I think it's exciting as a scientific
problem just as he described I I
honestly don't see a better way to enter
than talking about warmth and love and
Matt I don't think I've ever had such a
wonderful conversation where my
questions were so bad and your answers
was so beautiful so I deeply appreciate
I really enjoyed it
very fun I don't know I as you can
probably tell I'm I really you know I
there's something I like about kind of
thinking outside the box and like yeah
so it's good having fun to do that
awesome
thanks so much for doing
you